foreign
[Music]
up
okay so these bricks is floating here
popping this pipe we're on our way it's
the only way to fly man
oh wow
[Music]
oh here we are Palace doors
if you can finish this you're coming
with me watch and learn
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
oh my God okay
all right
me now ah you got the cat box oh my I'm
sorry okay now you die
oh we're the Mario brothers and plummets
again we're not like the others who get
all the things
we're faster than the others you'll be
hooked on the brothers
thank you Super Mario Bros it seems like
the only thing you haven't drained is my
bank account
for Super Service call or text Super
Mario Bros Plumbing today at
92955 Mario or reach us on the world
wide web at smbplumbing.com
this reminds me of being in my friend's
mom's basement here his parents argue
from upstairs
[Music]
when's the last time you guys have
played Mario Kart I play occasionally I
actually legit enjoy my video games he's
an active gamer you're an active gamer
Christian it's been a minute I feel like
it's like riding a bike you feel
confident no I don't know how to ride a
bike Charlie you look confident I'm not
okay Seth was the last time you played
Mario
but I've spent most of high school not
making friends and playing this game
instead buckle up
are you Luigi yeah I'm I'm Donkey Kong
I'm going Toadette so everybody's just
picking their own characters except for
Jack Jack's going on a strategic I hate
Sam but I think Jack blacks
there we go
all right oh I already something already
happened I'm in 12th not bad how are you
jack I think your strategy is good
bro
you need to come straight on when
we play car this is yeah I'm in the car
movies little mushroom people
God Seth great shot
all right let's see what do we got here
what do we got oh
you told that that was me just so you
know oh I got ink face Luigi you anchor
did I do that I'm done Charlie I'm still
losing in all these guys what's really
between me and Josh
someone just got me who got me oh yeah
that was your brother Luigi
oh my God that was a perfect Sonic Blast
oh no that was something oh no dude
for so long
are you guys done oh man
we all picked Jack right we did yeah
Jack was the winner how's that number
one see the Super Mario Brothers movie
only in theaters on April 5th
I wanna go
back
[Music]
where am I
oh fresh meat for the grinder pay him no
heat
[Music]
gotta be a way out of here there's no
escape the only hope is the story
release of death whoa oh you've got to
be kidding me
whatever those things are oh
we will destroy the Mushroom Kingdom
Bowser is coming I'm not afraid I'll do
anything for my brother we're going to
save him
you asked for it this is fun here
go
attack
and this
oh
foreign
[Music]
not sure if you know who I am but I'm
about to rule the world
wow uh yay but there's one problem
there's a human has a mustache just like
you
do you think I know every human being
with a mustache wearing an identical
outfit with a hat with the letter of his
first name on it because I don't
Bowser is coming
together we
are going to stop that monster how look
at us we're remarkable oh I got this no
problem
yes
come on Mario our big adventure begins
now ah get it off get it up get it off
there's a huge Universe out there
with a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us
no pressure
wahoo
[Music]
foreign
that is but a taste of our Fury
do you yield
I do not
I finally found it now who's gonna stop
me
foreign
what is this place
do not touch that mushroom you'll die oh
I'm sorry that one's perfectly fine come
on Mario
Mushroom Kingdom Here We Come
[Music]
foreign